logan standing on the left side coach to
be sport logan Murdoch NBC Sports Bay
Area you guys got off scored pretty big
in the third quarter what how did he get
away from you tried from the beginning
of the quarter you know Kauai had two
threes immediately and they turned up
their defense and they just got on a run
and we just we just sort of lost that
defensive tenacity that we had in the
first half
right standing coach Dan divine from the
ringer um
coached in divine from the ringer
uncomfortable position to be in but not
one you haven't seen before down 3-1
what can you take from your past
experience being on the brink as you try
to get the guys ready for Game five you
just you just try to win one game that's
you know that's what we did a few years
ago against OKC when one game and then
you move forward so that's our focus now
is you know we'll fly to Toronto
tomorrow and take a look at the film see
what we can do better and try to win a
game we've won a lot of games over the
years so try to win another one third
row over here
CJ Peters in San Francisco Examiner
Steve obviously watched 36 really
carried Toronto tonight but Serge Ibaka
is 20 really hurt you guys you know he's
really active them pick and roll what
was so hard about guarding search
tonight he just got it going and they
they did a good job in the second half
of moving the ball and finding the open
man they hit eight threes in the second
half after we we did a good job on them
in the first and so the ball started
moving and and they found Serge it you
know in the pockets and in the middle of
the paint several times and he had a
great game towards the middle Nate
Duncan dunked on a podcast coach this is
the most of your defense has struggled
in the series since you've been here
what's been the issue for you guys
defensively in the series we're playing
a really good team that moves the ball
and I think we've had our moments
defensively but we haven't been able to
string together the stops over the
course of a game that we've needed to so
I give them the credit they've they've
just played really well offensively and
they got a lot of threats out there a
lot of
shooters a lot of pastors and so they're
playing well and we've got a we got to
do better
Phil for throwing the right pasty Phil
barber Santa Rosa press Democrat it
seemed like Steph struggled to find
shots for a lot of the evening what were
you trying to do to get him shots man
what in retrospect could you have done
more well we'll take a look at the tape
but you know we've been playing a
certain style for for a long time here
and you know the ball moves and steps
one of the great off ball cutters in the
league and can play both on and off the
ball and so we're trying to mix up you
know the different things that we do and
you know I it wasn't his best game but
he'll bounce back Tim in the back left
Steve Tim Reynolds with the AP obviously
I'm sure it's a very down room right now
for obvious reasons how important is it
to sort of find some find some morale in
the next 72 hours how important how
daunting do you think that task will be
as you try to stave this thing I don't
mind I don't I don't think it's daunting
at all you know we we go to Toronto and
you know this is what we do for a living
we play basketball so we look forward to
playing another basketball game and in
an exciting atmosphere and the ultimate
test NBA Finals so I think we look at it
as a challenge and obviously we've got
to lick our wounds tonight tough loss
but you know a games a few days away
we'll have plenty of energy and we'll be
ready to go again in the back run Steve
run quickly can the safe just for
Chronicle you talk a little bit about
stuff did the Raptors approach him any
differently defensively given when he
did the other night
and obviously some of that is affected
by Clay's presence how did how did that
sort of match how did you think late why
tonight clay was amazing I mean you know
with a tweaked hamstring to do what he
did
Looney as well you know coming coming in
and playing 20 minutes you know given
his injury status so both those guys are
they're warriors no pun intended you
know they they just compete compete
compete and I'm really proud of both of
them both played really well but again
it just mean it wasn't enough in terms
of our team effort standing on your
right Monty Monty Poole NBC Sports Bay
Area Stevie first half you guys I think
go in at halftime you're up for was
there a sense that you could have been
up by more me and all the turnovers that
kept coming even in the second half how
much is that played a role in what
happened tonight just turning the ball
over the empty possessions yeah I think
the turnovers hurt us and yeah we
probably played well enough in the first
half to to be up eight or ten but that's
you know that's not abnormal in the NBA
you know they stayed in the game with
their free throws in the first half I
think they made 10 to our two and that
kept it close while they were struggling
offensively and again you know they
start out the third with Kauai hits two
straight threes to give him the lead and
I thought there was a surge of energy
for them at that point and that was a
really key moment those first few
minutes of the third quarter did last
two questions third row and then Chapel
were gonna write grant cone Santa Rosa
press Democrat
Steve you guys have to take three in a
row now from a team has taken five or
six from use it's the season where do
you go from here how much better do you
guys have to play to win this series we
go to Toronto and we try to win a game
that's it's as simple as that so we're
not thinking about winning three games
we're thinking about winning one game
and that's the task so I know we're
capable you got a lot of talent and we
got a lot of pride and these guys have
been to the finals five straight years
for a reason they're unbelievably
competitive and and they're together and
they're gonna fight they're gonna fight
the whole way so we'll go try to get one
win and if we can do that come back here
and see what happens
Jeff on the right rado Bay Area News
Group Steve one of the most competitive
guys obviously his dream on
seems like he came out in the first half
was playing his brains out on defense
second half it looked like he lost this
guy a few times what did you think of
his play tonight Oh dream on played
he played so hard tonight
out there the first half the intensity
level was incredible just to see the
athleticism and the defense of energy by
both teams it was it was amazing and
draymond always right at the center of
all that one of the best defenders I've
ever seen and he's flying around and
doing his thing and covering everybody
and and then offensively you know
handling the ball and trying to trying
to distribute the ball to our shooters
and so dream on always makes a huge
impact on the game and and I thought he
did tonight but again it was a group
effort
and we didn't have enough as a group to
win the game